attention tu fais ça j'ai confondu suite
a confondu ça fait trois semaines qui se
prépare pour cette édition il a regardé
le match le moment venu après mais je
pense pas je pense que j'ai deux fils
guillaume si j'avais été un arctique en
tête au centre de formation je me suis
occupé spécialement nuit aujourd'hui
c'est aux rebelles vous êtes concentré
ses premiers souvenirs
ma première ivresse
ah bon cet accord c'était peu ça fait
dix on vous avait 22 ans
premier choc
j'aimais quand j'ai récité une poésie
dans ma classe c'était en ce2 ah oui et
ça vous à ça vous a plu vous ai dit
c'est ça que je veux faire et 90 a
vraiment fait j'ai eu une part
monstrueuse que les mensonges du nom
s'est passé pas mal le mensonge en ça
permet d'inventer une réalité meilleur
je crois que j'ai pratiqué très tôt
c'est une proche c'est une tranche comme
elles sont jetées lady avait fait
hypokhâgne ans n'a aucune chance
premier péché ya pas de pêcher ouais
le but c'est rien mais pêché rien
premières amours
il faut que je dise quoi premièrement
non vous n'êtes pas obligés de donner le
nom l'adresse ça vous dit il avait pas
en voilà qu'en sais tu peux tu petit
j'imagine c'était non j'étais passé le
titre c'était un garçon blond avec une
queue de cheval comme sahin qui baissent
à nouveau mon collège nous étions c'est
un garçon premier baiser sur un
skateboard et une acrobate ce qu'il
était tout petit avant premier flirt
poussé jeudi rama yade et avec la langue
et tout ça mais c'était c'était le
premier de la queue de cheval
non c'était le scan bronn scpa première
idole aznavour peut-être première belle
robe
j'avais une robe en lapin comme un
premier amour je sais qui c'est moi
avoue c'est celui de nantes à qui vous
est venue à paris non ouais c'est ça
et alors alors là ça devient chaud
première fois à 2 pour la fois que
j'avais fait l'amour à deux avec un
garçon ou une fille première fois il ya
longtemps
ben c'était le mot merci
ah bon vous prêt à vous en sortir comme
ça je vais pas vous demander la première
fois trois parce qu'ici non pas ça parce
qu'ici on est ici on est discret dont je
mangerai pas la première fois trois
premières fois 4 jamais je n'ai pas
encore essayé avec 22 en même temps
première rupture première rupture
c'était à 18 ans c'est super on fait non
je peux vous demander à quel âge avait
filmé votre premier pétard parce que ça
c'est de la provocation facile première
ligne alors vous n'êtes pas obligé de
répondre premier succès premier succès
mais c'est là c'est la sibérie c'est
pour ça que cette date ou morale assez
clair et bientôt la première la première
ligne
en premier échec je me connais c'est
terminal de jérôme salle et même voix la
première chose que vous faites le matin
au réveil je prends une douche le matin
moi je veux pas de douche je sais un
tweet je fais c'est inconscient j'ai vu
ça dans un film crtv
ouais je me passe la main j'ai un grand
short mondial de foot des essais et je
me passe la main mais c'est inconscient
après je vois mon café vient bien tu te
fais car aucune chance aucune chance
dans la mécanique ça parce que je sais
faire plein de mecs mais c'est
inconscient s'est souvent fait sa
dernière volonté si vous deviez mourir
là maintenant c'est important dit de
venir nous grand profit de venir à nancy
ah bon c'est tout c'est pas plus chaud
que ça mais c'est très chaud avant merci
on va faire une interview première fois
[Musique]
non
parfait plus personne ne bouge pas j'ai
repris le pouvoir
premier choc l'opéra premier premier
première résultats d'examens à l'opéra
contre les filles s'est essayé de se
jeter sous les voitures de se taper la
tête contre les murs premier mensonge
souvenirs je déteste le mensonge jouer
le rôle d'une menteuse away menteuse
elle non allemands elle s'invente sa vie
est rêve sa vie à une intégriste du 2
la vérité bien premier péché je crois
pas au pis si vous croyez pas empêché
non car oui monsieur me croyez pas vos
péchés ailleurs le suicide tue et oui
oui c'est tout à part ça il n'y a pas de
péché je sais pas moi vous savez elle
n'est pas catholique comme vous c'est
peut-être pour ça mais moi j'ai été
élevé là dedans en nous en avons aussi
premier amour une dizaine d'années vient
enfin quand j'avais une dizaine d'années
alors la veste et si ça c'est pas
oublier non premier baiser une cour
d'école sombre dans une déception
ah bon vous accueillez déception alors
après ça va mieux premier flirt poussé à
une belle histoire a enfin une belle
histoire
maintenant rien faire pousser et qu'on
va pousser jeu quand tu mets un peu la
main toi c'est quoi pousser pour toi
j'en sais plus celle ci est bien sûr une
petite bise
c'est là non premier vrai amour
oui le premier flirt poussé correspond
au premier vrai amour est pas mal ah oui
ça va mieux la première rupture ça avec
lui aussi deux jours après non non pas
deux jours quand même attendu il fait de
la peine à combien non quelques jours
après après on s'est remis en a souffert
voilà ans et repousse sa première cuite
sa date de cette époque
oui oui je devais avoir une quinzaine
d'années ouais je veux faire la maligne
une bonne bouteille de vodka ça me
faisait rien et puis je suis tombé
premier pétard même époque
non non je fais une pente trop plus tard
non non je vais essayer oui terre
regarde oui tu peux aller chercher une
bière dans le frigo va fermer les volets
fermés
non cette époque ouais premier succès
j'ai pas dire l'institutrice je me faire
pousser mais non c'est un sujet dont on
pouvait dire ça sans succès c'est la
première fois qu'on m'a fait confiance
c'est vrai mais bon si la confiance est
votre premier rôle dans tous les cas pas
oui
r la faire pour mieux vous connaître on
va faire une interview première fois
[Musique]
premier souvenir la première scène avec
notre dame peut-être ouais ouais
premier choc la première scène avec
notre dame premier mensonge la première
scène est de vous faire chier maintenant
premières amours on était tout petit
ah bon ouais ouais ça tombe sous le coup
de la loi
voilà c'est le premier homme c'est quand
un bisou avec la langue ça c'est bien
je vais préparer le bisou avec la langue
aussi je m'en veux de la bouche bien
bien première idole whitney houston
premier disque
moi je savais qu'ils s'étaient sénat
ouais j'aime pas trop le dire deux jours
avec je peux pas avoir prétendu vraiment
avoir travaillé avec je te dise que
c'est avec lenny kravitz
oui j'ai ris de veau deuxième disque
avec avec pas si oui qu'est d'ailleurs
que sur l'album sur la balle que la
premier vrai grand amour
même si ce n'est pas encore arrivé dit
le soyons honnêtes nombreux
téléspectateurs qui sont intéressés que
sont pas validées le savoir non je crois
oissel saison première cuite avec notre
dame
d'ailleurs c'était la seule et l'unique
à pascal m'a dégoûté ouais ouais ouais
c'était pour mieux s'y passe quasimodo
j'avais gare où j'avais garé ou à gauche
a vu je suis à droite je me souviens pas
et puis j'ai une bizarrerie bois un
petit peu et hinton un peu de retard et
puis et un et deux et puis le troisième
et là j'ai fini dans les toilettes pour
venir raconter pas parce qu'il ya un
ministre de la république à ce discret
premier pétard non jamais ah bon ça m'a
jamais il n'a pas sur lui nos premiers
succès donc notre dame de paris
les premiers échecs non
l'amitié avec hélène ségara alors ça
aurait pu être une belle histoire c'est
vrai vous avez pas un peu ça regretter
quoi j'aurais pu devenir amis
alors maintenant c'est ce qu'on va faire
un quitus qui maintenant on va faire une
interview première fois on ne bouge pas
pour les couches pendant l'été galles
[Applaudissements]
alors interdit première fois vous êtes
concentré de leur s à attention
attention attention attention premier
souvenir ça commence soft premiers
souvenirs de votre vie bon celui qui me
vient c'est une petite cabane à trinidad
où j'ai vu mon arrière-grand-mère avec
plein de petits poussins jaunes et moi
qui étais dans l habiter dans une espèce
de petit cabanon et jallet derrière dans
sa pratique et ses poudres
ouais déjà pour maquiller way attendu
j'ai dit non j'ai dit oui et non j'ai
passé à gedeon comment ce soft
effectivement là c'est ça mais bon
premier choc choc quand ma mère sortait
en boîte de nuit j'étais très jaloux
j'avais déjà sept ans est sorti bon avec
des amis mais je me rappelle et je
comprenais pas pourquoi moi je pouvais
pas y aller aussi première baffe mon
père la seule fois qui m'a giflé c'est
je pense qu'une adolescente
insupportable une fois je pourrais à
j'ai fait des choses terribles et là je
lui avais dit que j'ai pas pris mais mes
devoirs de mal je n'allais pas les faire
de toute façon mais après ma c'est une
mamie contre le mur la photo en bas mais
d'isère savoie
c'était comme ça mais pour un mec était
un peu baba pourquoi c'était génial
c'était vraiment génial et je le
remercie vous en garder un bon souvenir
super man ce jeu n'est pas devenu maso
quand même nom mais j'aime quelqu'un qui
se laisse j'aime pas un homme qui se
laisse faire et je l'avait poussée à ses
limites je crois premier objet fétiche
objet fétiche un soutien gorge avec des
pois bleus dessus ça monte doucement et
premier péché pouvait tout dire le
monseigneur est parti mentir je veux
monter beaucoup à deux centièmes entier
un petit manoir c'est fini
pas tout à fait prêt premiers flirts
premier flat dans le sud ouest
à présent je me suis fait embrasser par
un garçon de 18 ans qui pensait que j'en
avais 16 ouais c'était votre premier
rhum après annonce non à baiser je
trouve ça vraiment premier c'est bien un
premier homme c'est bien plus tard
première femme première femme
non non un petit buzz est innocent ah
oui premier vrai amour mais vraiment je
pense
il a été plate au nic mais j'en étais
malade
ah oui première mouture première rupture
je suis encore avec l'homme que j'aime
donc la haye
bon ben on va rentrer voilà bon ben
voila c'était tout le monde ment pas
rendez vous samedi prochain
[Applaudissements]
première fois trois jamais à 4 g
bon j'arrête votre premier vive premier
livre dont je me souvienne c'est à 12
ans c'est l'idiot de dostoïevski web
vous initier à dostoïevski à 12 ans je
le remercie encore ah ouais ça a du bon
les papa baba et les femmes première
cuite au cccc un nouvel an dernier la
conclusion vraiment voulu quoi du
champagne du vin rouge est un cocktail
que ma soeur a préparé que tu es un truc
caïpirinha être comme ça j'étais pas
bien premier pétard je fume pas de
cigarettes
donc à chaque fois que j'essaie je
m'étouffe pendant une demi-heure après
vous êtes menteuse gc
là
quels sont les ibères
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est bien on voit que la beauce et bien
alors c'est une interview première fois
un premier choc
la perte d'un de quelqu'un de la famille
c'était la grand mère de mon père et
c'est là que j'ai vu mon père pour la
première fois pleurer ça ce terrain le
premier choc premières amours en
souvenez quand même ouais c'est j'avais
je crois trois ou quatre ans les haras
mais bon c'est tout bon moral est la
bonne elle encourt bisous sous le préau
et c'est sa reste très très gentil
est-ce que l'histoire de l'autre mais
qui vous a fait du mal ce n'était pas
l'histoire des grandes filles les autres
fouilles décernement malsain c'est un
amour qui fait souffrir saint amand dans
lequel on s'enferme justement c'est vous
alors que vous faites un cinoche
oui et non c'est inconscient allez vous
souvenir vers 12 13 ans
c'est quelque chose qui est très très
fréquent on se plaît à aimer quelqu'un
qui vous fait souffrir que ce soit en
amour en amitié voilà c'était bien la
peine d'y aller
[Applaudissements]
ces premiers baisers
oui mais ses bisous à la maternelle
justement ce premier roman en chaîne qui
rit ou un truc comme ça
bon la musique la langue et donc que ces
barques et la langue
c'était pitoyable je vais avoir songé
nous reste faible j'avais entre 12 et 13
ans je sais plus et je trouve ça
horrible je me souviens non mais je me
souviens je me souviens j'étais il y
avait une petite place un arrêt de bus
et je dis au revoir à ce garçon c'était
mon premier baiser avec la langue je me
suis retourné j'ai regardé mes copines
mais j'ai fait j'ai fais vraiment la
global
quand on a du succès des premiers
falloir pousser ses marques et l'aurait
poussé à j'avais c'était au mois de mai
un voyage à venise
voilà le cas l'année j'avais à venise à
12 ans et demi vient jamais entre
j'avais j'allais vers des 16 ans donc se
faire engueuler par alonso nous c'est
bon alors à pois zi première fois tout
mais on sait marquer c'est des questions
agitent la place mais je ne sais pas du
tout de mon âge
c
l'achat des voix
il était
comme cela comme ça je sais que les mecs
et du la vignette
mais non je ne sais pas quel âge mais
j'étais tendance est aussi annoncée
première fois tout mais alors le premier
vrai amour véritable amour le vrai
rencontre est déjà le premier parce que
là plusieurs devient pas très longtemps
avant le premier doit annoncer ya pas
très longtemps ça fait un an et demi
l'été il ya un an ces excuses ont été
bourrées dont les ruptures
elle a pas de rupture pas si première
vraie rupture dont je me souviens bien
qui maquille mais romain j'ai un peu de
mal à digérer
je crois que je venais d'avoir 14 ans
est ce qu'il ya une vraie rupture quand
il y a pas d'amour du tout mes éléments
sont vues communes comme il ya là mais
c'est de la manse et de l'amour de dado
c'est un truc on craque sur quelqu'un
reste avec lui deux mois et et puis
voilà et puis on se rend compte avec le
temps que c'est pas dit c'est pas de
l'amour mais que la rupture est toujours
une rupture la souffrance
oui à ce moment là oui alors vous reçoit
en plus ça normal et le pantalon je
demande ça fait était la copine m'a
finalement tu vois pas a livré à moi on
peut certainement mais sans voilà alors
c'est quoi première cuite c'est ça oh
mon dieu appelle le bernard c'était
tellement
on verra bientôt c'est
j'étais tellement pas bien conscients
tous entraînés par les amis tous comme
ça une émission d'ardisson était en
vacances à cholet a sur le mouchoir
voilà avec mes parents et j'étais parti
avec une amie et on a rencontré deux
jeunes parisiens vont vous trouvez
plutôt sympa et tout qu'ils un vrai
jouet tennis etc oui oui ce soir on fait
la fête on ramène des bouteilles et qui
la bière et je ne sais quoi et puis ben
je suis bien amasser voilà sans voile à
nos commandes je pense qu'il vaut lui
c'est parce que face aux parents
regardent
non mais ils s'aiment parce que je me
suis fait un peu choqué par maman sens
là mais c'est pas que tu partes un
moment que tes péchés pessah l'école
bah c est bien ce qu elle doit appuyer
sur ces clauses cherche veut la plus
sombre importe quoi on ne bouge pas king
ne bouge pas pendant les kings premier
baiser d'un saut quantique 13 12 cd lui
donne sa qualité son prénom
je sais pas si vous mentez et il est là
et là ce soir
non sérieusement oui c'est bastia c'est
bien vous êtes resté cinq mois en sorte
bravo bonne réponse alors en attendant
passé à la première fois tous les deux
tout nu dans un lit
vous avez quel âge s'est passé bastien
c'est un autre ce décalage
seize bravo et ça a duré combien de
temps deux minutes
non non la relation aux relations conter
des histoires 12 bravo bravo boissons
des biassais 2 200 votre premier casting
avait 13 ans sur deux c'était chez
filipacchi aux champs elysées jeune et
jolie première idole madonna première
fois première fois à troyes il ya enfin
un an et demi maintenant première fois 4
pas encore devant nous premier chagrin
d'amour
je n'ai pas eu un bon c'est parce que
vous avez pas encore aimer vraiment
peut-être vous savez c'est quoi la non
ça je sais pas premier premier jouanno
cabanis j'ai fait mon meilleur copain
mathieu jeu son père médecin à waimes
sous contrôle médical datant première
chose que vous faites le matin vous
révélions bien alors on va faire une
telle première fois
pendant le dîner coeur
michel plat pays
qu'ils aient mis un vems répondent avec
l'accent belge d'ailière des plus beaux
jeux les plus horribles dont va faire
l'interview première fois mais avec
l'accent normalement oui vraiment vous
le fait vachement bien bougé pendant 500
foyers des belges qui regarde à voile et
à tous les liégeois je vous embrasse
très voilà c'est bien on avait julie
snyder normalement ça fait déborder une
belle nana c'est exactement ce que je
pense des québécoises mois bonsoir et
gilles ménage qui est là bonsoir
alors votre premier souvenir mon premier
souvenir
l'action est à dire avec l'accent oui
premier souvient mon premier souvenir
le sourire de ma mère
non voilà je peux pas dire ça mais pas
comme ça
pourquoi accents le sourire de ma mère
c'est beaucoup mieux déjà premier choc
de votre vie moi quand j'ai appris que
le père noël n'existait pas on peut pas
dire comme ça quand j'ai appris que le
père noël n'existait pas
j'ai été vraiment choqués voilà non mais
c'est vrai non oui mais ça refroidit
tout le monde sur l'accord jolie fille
comme ça et ça tu sais je ne veux plus
c'est pourquoi j'ai pourquoi je fais ça
pour pas être amoureux bon maintenant je
vous libère de l'accent belge parce
qu'on rentre dans des questions
compliquées qui tue donc je ne veux pas
que vous soyez pertes sur 300 sionisme
premiers amours premières amours martin
il s'appelle martin était plus âgées que
vous non même âge même un jeu quel âge à
quel âge c'était
16 ans à 16 ans datant du 16 ans oui
j'étais très prude un trait aux
minguettes à quel âge luis très jeune
oui ces dangers graves aussi scolaire
suivante tu vas la pause et alors
premier visé exactement fernandez il
pourrait la faire à ma place c'était
mission maintien remet baiser premier
baiser c'était dans la cour de l'école
en fait je fantasmais sur un type et je
crois que je l'échoppé il était en short
c'était un cours de gym un et je sais
pas pourquoi je me suis avancé vers lui
et j'ai embrassé sur la bouche
ça a été assez magique ouais voilà
c'était exactement comme avec luchini
dans bach mais finalement vous êtes pas
beaucoup changé ça c'était sans la
langue ou avec la langue sans
enregistrements les premiers baisers
avec la langue
enfin c'était moins bien ah bon pourquoi
ça vous dégoûter la langue non mais je
m'en étais fait tout un monde enfin et
en fait non non non avant c'était qui
hervé ben haddou il s'appelait au nom
les géniaux bon premier flirt poussé
flirt poussé ben c'était c'était à 17
ans dans une cabane dans la crau la la
la la la première fois pour de vrai ah
d'accord ça s'étend loeffler poussé
parce que j'entends je pas commencé en
belgique mais ce que j'entends par
fleurs poussent et on fait beaucoup de
choses mais on ne fait pas la chose
moi je me rappelle que de là vraiment la
bagarre est d'acord c'était la manger
quoi on mangeait des miels potes ça vous
à marcq la madeleine à moi c'est sa
première fois à trois et vous mets toi
c'est à troyes dans l'aube donc ça
moi j'étais bien trop longtemps
voilà c'était mon meilleur ami donc
c'était et sa fiancée et c'est pas moi
c'est non laurent laurent bon j'en dirai
pas plus bon d'accord première fois à 4
ah ça non
premier chagrin d'amour t'as combien là
parce que j'ai du mal à suivre
premier chagrin d'amour la première fois
je devais avoir 20 ans j'étais amoureuse
d'un funambule qui m'a laissé tomber
comme une vieille chaussette pour qu on
va travailler proportionnelle fils et
ongles première cuite première cuite
c'était je crois en pologne sous comme
un polonais ont dû toujours bêtement
pologne georges a même eu trop de vodka
ont tourné dans les tatras
on était dans un hôtel qui ressemble à
un pelage à celui de shining voilà donc
on se console est temps qu'on pouvait
dans la vodka première cigarette au
cabanis jeunes aujourd'hui j'aime pas
comment vous émission vous poser la
question sur le cabanis d'accord hervé
première cigarette au cabanis ya pas
très longtemps c'était à la jamaïque web
a marqué vous vous bourrez en pologne
vous fumez vous fumez vers la jamaïque
vous êtes
quelque chose au bon endroit roues en
grèce les anglais mais c'est bien
première chose que vous faites le matin
en vous réveillant je me rende à la très
bonne réponse dernière chose que vous
faites le soir avant de vous coucher je
me passe de la crème sur les pieds
jaunes les pieds non mais moi
et avant de vous endormir dernière chose
que vous faites c'est quoi avant de vous
coucher omettez de lachlan jolis pieds
des rebelles bouchon de la crète
avant de vous endormir mais en fait non
je parle pas de trucs de sexe vous
pouvez faire une prière vous pouvez
faire votre examen de conscience
voilà vous avez l'air sincère quand on
vous dit que ça
parisien
fabrice luchini et
dambach me
bruno chiche voilà internes et/ou
première fois c'est le cas de le dire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
interview première fois premier souvenir
quand je me suis noyée
vous êtes noyer et quand j'ai toujours
non à bandol
je m'inscris dans une piscine et ma mère
m'a repêché de justesse quand j'avais
deux ans ah ouais et en fait c'est
bizarre parce que j'ai le souvenir des
carreaux bleus quand je coulais c'était
agréable ne s'était pas désagréable
premier mensonge je sais pas mentir
premier péché je vois pas qu'est ce qui
est un péché avec la première baffe
jamais jamais et si une fois dans un
film
c'était dans la vraie vie non non ah si
une fois un type 1 type que je
connaissais pas non parce qu'en fait moi
je parle beaucoup et j'aime bien voyez
des petites vannes assez méchante et un
jour quelqu'un l'a très mal pris et je
me suis pris une baffe premier coup de
foudre
mon amour est ce qui fait la zai non
c'est moi je suis né à zain un bon
d'accord premier baiser sur la bouche
sans la langue je suis pas non ça n'est
pas non en fait c'est usant voilà ouais
ouais annoncée très tard et est traité
avec les décalages trop tard non je ne
dirais pas c'est la honte
ouais genre 12 13 ans non 16
ouais première fois toute nue avec un
garçon boucher pareil
oui c'est tout un monde c'était le jour
il fallait être là quoi c'était la
première fois à troyes jamais jamais
encore atteint même pas encore n'ont
jamais ça vous voulez pas ça vous
intéresse pas vraiment à ce pas du tout
du tout du tout du tout pour foix iv
donc ces imbéciles de vous le demander
pour sa santé
premier chagrin d'amour dix sept rangs
mais en fait non
non parce que non j'ai pas non en fait
c'est bête mais je regrette d'avoir eu
un chagrin d'amour pour lui ouais ne
méritait pas ça quand même bien voilà la
première scène de ménage avec sud et la
times je crois jamais jamais encore si
wesh
j'ai mon caractère ah bon ouais je
m'énerve je claque la porte et tout ça
dure pas longtemps
alors maintenant ça dure pas longtemps
non j'y arrive pas vous avez pas son nom
reste attaché avec chaque pas ouais
c'est ça vous fait la tête vous fait du
mal donc vous retourne à qui revient le
premier c'est vous c'est lui noir à la
tête attention pas être soumise comme sa
première il résiste pas pardon il
résiste pas et donc je comprends un peu
en même temps première cuite datant
encore en fait je spécial coup je ne
bois pas d'alcool mais ce qui me saoule
c'est le coca
une autre cocasse à soulac rien non non
c'est non mais c'est vrai ah bon mais je
dis que l'économie ait pas d'alcool
malouda déjà cultes y suit les lasagnes
premier pétard ben en fait je suis mon
pad plus tard mais je fume passivement
parce que je suis fan de concert de
reggae donc d'accord si votre relation
vous dépensez vous avez des concerts
variés
je resterai suffit première cigarette
autorisé sept ans avec maman c'est un
way et votre mère vous laisser fumer
réseau s'étend elle m'a fait essayer
j'ai trouvé ça tellement dégueulasse que
je n'ai plus jamais et jeune fille ou
pas ben prochain film c'est quoi c'est
la dario prochaine fois non non non
prochain image en effet un autre après
qui s'appelle sexe 13 opposé d'eric
assous
non voyons non mais j'ai paroles très
important dans mon prochain film c'est à
voir
je ne sais pas encore votre mère du
journal au regard des petites annonces
non j'ai un agent maintenant quand même
alors on va enquêter comme un petit peu
sur vous sur votre vie comme vous êtes
très jeune on va faire une interview
première fois vous savez quand on est
moche parking
le premier mensonge auto quoi par
exemple je sais pas décorer la primaire
dès la maternelle je sais pas le très
venteuses faut s'en méfier
je serai hélène je viendrai chercher
tout de suite thierry lhermitte votre
premier choc ya pas très longtemps
1 oui oui on va trop en parler à la
première baffe
c'était avec mon papa
j'étais petit il voulait dormir il était
fatigué c'est un dimanche après midi
moi j'étais très nerveuse courait dans
tous les sens j'étais avec mon petit
magnétophone et je faisais peut-être un
petit peu de bruit
c'était peut-être la goutte qui a fait
déborder le vase on supprime sa way et
pourtant le vous lui en voulez pas vous
habitait toujours chez lui oui votre
premier aïd al issaoui
kolo
c'est un stage là ils ont besoin de se
sentir aimé désiré merci de votre
premier baiser sans la langue la
maternelle ah ouais mais j'avais pas de
chance parce que j'étais amoureuse d'un
garçon qui me trouvais pas joli non plus
du coup à son copain ou partie des
copains d'accord c'était une tournante
donc ça c'était sans la langue après
votre premier baiser avec la lande
treize ans au lol alors ça s'est fait
laminer le lendemain matin dix ans est
définie ouais c'est dégueulasse d'accord
qu'elle briseuse de coeur
la première fois tout seul non c'est une
question alors j'vais vous dire la
vérité sur cette question j'y avais pas
pensé et j'ai reçu non mais c'est vrai
j'ai reçu un email d'un mec qui me dit
quand tu fais l'interview première fois
tu te demandes toujours la première fois
de la première fois à 3 pourquoi tu
demande pas la première fois tout seul
vous en souvenez pas non jamais tout
seul non ah bon la première fois deux
j'étais jeune on fait trois gènes
gouvernement avant la patience maman
oulala c'est que j'ai deux filles là ça
m'inquiète parce que j'entends ce soir
maintenant on innove elle vous couchez
première fois à troyes ah bon ça vous
intéresse pas les batteries ou du tout
du tout 1-4 non plus donc encore
j'arrête là c'est pas les chiffres
impairs
ce cas les sites par un bon premier
chagrin d'amour à 15 1 à 15 ans déjà
vous avez tout fait ou à l'âge de 15 ans
était finie c'était la première fois que
je tombais amoureuse première fois que
je me donnais à quelqu'un vous avez
souffert d'un mois j'étais folle
amoureuse lui même et a dû tout pourrait
donc c'était juste pour tirer son coup
comment te dire vulgairement donc j'en
étais malade après ça vous a commencé à
boire première cuite secor première
cuite et mais j'ai jamais une première
cuite mais c'est ce soir alors jamais
vous n'êtes jamais encore un verre deux
verres pas plus c'est bien premier
pétard donc 16 ans 16 ans par dont 7 en
or 16 ans oui j'ai ça parce que votre
mère regard non non non c'est vrai 16
d'hervé bourges comment vous émission
vous poser la question sur le cap à nice
d'accord hervé première cigarette 14 ans
ouais comme et valium pas encore bravo
vous félicite vous allez avoir droit ça
ne vous étonnera pas à une interview
première fois en amour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il n'a pas bougé alors attention
attention premier souvenir
je sais quand je sautais sur le lit de
ma cousine et je suis tombé je me suis
déchiré le dos sur une étagère de
briques à venir à koji de la chapelle
alors ouais la cause et n'a eu la chance
fait mal oui premier choc j'imagine que
c'est celui-là premier choc
ben non j'ai déjà pris un choc
électrique en voulant jouer à la voiture
que j'avais décliné dans ce que j'avais
des clés j'allais rentrer dans la plus
de courant c'est comme tomber quoi
québécoise à 4 ans et je le fais aussi
on en a dénombré 110 à l'époque les
mange au premier mensonge off ça doit
être une fois que j'ai dit à ma mère
c'est pas moi ouais c'est sûr minceur
premier péché mon père non premier péché
oui le mensonge
ah ouais enfin c'est quelqu'un que je
sais pas lequel première baffe
j'en ai jamais eu jamais essayé sur
cette même essayé ma fille tu es mort
ont des toits badar il fera peut-être
curé tué de curel corée oui mon fichu
mais il est complètement paumé première
idole céline dion
là on est en réponse mais moi j'aime
beaucoup même si vertueux non c'est vrai
oui les derniers seront les premiers est
une des plus belles chances
il aime céline dion elvis presley n'est
pas mort belle robe âgées jamais portera
à l'eurovision et bientôt que j'ai
maintenant à l'eurovision je vais mettre
une robe donc si elle est belle ce sera
la première premier coup de foudre
premier coup de foudre
je sais pas je veux être à peu près
faisant quinze ans 15 ans et alors alors
ben ça a été mon premier mon premier
copain sérieux et alors quoi alors après
alors que je devrais j'ai eu un autre
coup de foudre
je sors un livre chez latex je veux
qu'on en parle comme ça votre promo
quand même de votre site est pas trompé
pour apprêter de requins savez très bien
marché premier baiser sur la bouche
14 15 1 première fois avec la langue
ah bah je pensais que ces que je n'es
pas d'accord au québec c'est comme si on
mélange tout de suite des fois oui des
fois non première fois à 2 à 2 j'ai pas
demandé première fois tout seul parce
que bon je peux pas avec le père qui est
là et tout changer parce que j'ai couché
avec un mec savoir je devais avoir la
fin de mes 15 ans presque c'est ce tabou
choc mais de tout ça très bien première
fois la 3g pages qu'il a fait sien mais
jamais encore non c'est pour ça que vous
non en france la première fois à 4 je
vous le demande
premier chagrin d'amour premier chagrin
d'amour il ya
neuf mois à peu près abbas était donc
voilà donc c'était ouais c'était c'était
mon ancien copain c'est à la première
fois au lit par nonu ah bah oui on est
restés des très bons c'est très sympa
mais c'est pas qu'on était des très bons
copains le premier mois après la rupture
mais maintenant oui bon appui première
cuite c'était juste après alors non là
c'était avant première cuite c'est à
chez mes parents je devais avoir 15 ans
à 15 ans étaient magasin vraiment a dit
demain je baise premier pétard premier
pétard jamais bon
[Applaudissements]
il en existe elle et moi attendaient non
à la radio npr
non j'en doute ailleurs soyons clairs
ouais je vois pas en quoi la religion
catholique pourrait nous interdire de
fumer des pétards attendait du marché
n'y a pas de descendance oui d'accord
mais sveta l'ehpad et maintenant c'est
que ça aide beaucoup et ça peut avoir du
bon
dans lesquelles des gens quand le
concert à qui on fait fumer des pétards
ouais match du temps c'est pas la peine
d'attendre d'avoir le cancer
je le dis aux bons première cigarette
là c'est beaucoup plus grand mais non
plus ben ça c'est bien cela je vous
félicite le premier valium jamais c'est
bien bravo bravo bravo
maya
on ne bouge pas pendant l'été une gueule
on ne bouge pas pendant le jingle bien
ça c'est fait alterview première fois
premier souvenir
la première fois à tout de suite oui
c'est un truc dont on parle de sexe ou
j'y pense mais ça aurait pu être sympa
mois introduites avant 13 ans vous avez
commencé tard en plus 15 ans et demi
perdez c'est à dire premier choc de
votre vie si mauvais temps du sexe n ya
pas longtemps c'était avec un membre de
ma famille
j'ai voulu jouer sur tenue et
je vais me gêner premier mensonge il n'a
pas duré longtemps c'est une tromperie
le trompe et vague
oui bon mais ça a duré deux jours que je
le jure on est déçus il a fait avant moi
c'est scandaleux ces destructions durant
tête premier péché la gourmandise créé
premier homme à mon papa ouais premier
coup de foudre
greg grèce aux grecs quand même premier
baiser sans la langue la langue c'était
tort
ah bon j'ai commencé avec la langue j'ai
déjà mon premier mac comme brice mach
beauté attendait jeu c'était en
quatrième quel zébié garcia n'ont pas
quel âge
sa maison est alors maintenant il est
avec la langue avec la langue avec la
langue si tu t'es pas non plus la
première fois alors danse avec greg
oui à l'âge de 16 ans oui je dis oui
comme ça parce qu'il ya eu un effet avec
quelqu'un de rompre mais c'était un très
mauvais souvenir
ah bon c'est pas bien passé ma première
vraie foi voilà des premières fois avec
une fille c'était pour c'était pour
l'anniversaire de greg je comprends pas
heureusement plus souvent préparé un
petit cadeau
regarde exactement c'est une fille dont
j'avais envie et finalement c'est pas
prévu on était dans une soirée tout ça
et on est rentrés tous les trois voies
la règle il n'a pas vu la grèce bien
bravo et félicitations à ces situations
très béni des dieux
vous rentrez jamais vécu
j'inclus pouvait avoir des copains oui
il pourrait avoir envie de rentrer
quelques copains vague aussi frais que
ce soit moi qui en ai envie ah bon c'est
vous qui décidez oui je pense que c'est
normal dans un couple que ce soit la fin
mais la femme a plus besoin de choses
pour le sexe comme un homme c'est assez
facile et pas mal c'est bien enfin
souvent une fille a plus besoin d'eux
des choses pour donc première fois à
troyes vous venez de le dire première
fois 4 on va tout dire c'était y'a pas
longtemps et a5 jamais ah bon vous êtes
tout à apprendre encore premières scènes
de ménage quand même j'espère passer à
londres dans un beau coup de pub ah ben
oui on discute beaucoup un nom aime bien
vous aimez bien pour la réconciliation
merci bien sûr les premiers amours c'est
qui votre premier vrai premier amant sur
pareil non
progenics et l'après
c'est un fait
alors look main c'est la première fois
que tu montes parle de vous donc on va
vous faire une interview première fois
[Musique]
le premier souvenir mon premier souvenir
lenny kravitz voilà j'ai rencontré à 16
ans et dans un bar vous avez parlé
ah oui je vais parler j'ai une grande
photo là un beau portrait c'est tout
fier
premier mensonge strato un très très tôt
très toi je devais avoir 6 ans si l'on
traite première baffe très tôt aussi il
existe athées mensongère mais c'est quoi
ce que j'ai fait mais je pense même ma
grande soeur m'avait surpris on préfère
des bisous à un garçon jeanne est ravi
non non non pas encore non non mais
voilà et puis ça se faisait pas dans la
famille une version première fois que
vous avez fait pleurer votre mère quand
je suis parti de chez moi que l'âge 16
ans première injustice dont vous ayez
été victime je dirais
jetez moi j'irai le décès de mon frère
mais je sais pour moi c'est une
injustice mais qui est pas toi voilà
premier jour à l'école
très bien jamais bien l'école huawei se
contenterait premières vacances
va-t-on j'ai avec mes parents oui comme
l'un des leurs rob les jours du mariage
de ma soeur j'y ai droit une très jolie
robe pour les coups de foudre à 20 ans
avec un quelqu'un dont 13 beaucoup plus
justement les bières déclaration d'amour
chez maman l'entarteur godin pour les
baisers sur la bouche
je les fais très rarement mon premier
baiser sur la bouche
je vais avoir 15 ans un truc comme ça
oui je suivais les copines parce que
tout le monde avait fait rose en moi
j'avais encore rien vu c'était avec la
langue
non c'était sans la langue et avec la
langue et avec la langue
ça a été bien plus tard wendy dans un
précoce première fois avec un garçon
première fois avec un garçon à 21 ans 2e
fois moi ça continue première fois à
troyes jamais à 4 les ruptures première
rupture
première grande rupture bain
ap ap ap j'avais 23 ans resté un mois et
demi avec m
c'est dur c'était dur oui c'était dur
mais j'ai souffert personnellement j'ai
souffert celle d un franchement
maintenant j'ai vraiment souffert
j'ai eu un moment de spleen terrible
écrit tu m'a pas répondu
je téléphonais théorêt station répondeur
c'est vrai que ça m'a pas plu du tout et
après quand j'ai su que tu avais un
petit enfant j'ai vraiment eu mal mais
maintenant quel effet ça te fait de me
revoir
vas y écoute j'aimerais bien qu'on se
parle un peu plus tard et puis qu'on
mette les choses on ne va pas
recommencer à zéro
ce serait bien que ça c'est pas ça se
discute
j'ai une situation très confortable mais
je passe dans l'émission d'ardisson
c'est comme tu veux c'est quand tu
voudras c'est comme quand vous vous
retrouvez ici tous les autres est
bizarre c'est fou ça c'est la vie c'est
le mektoub statut c'est incroyable parce
que certains en auraient besoin
c'est insensé et elle n'a pas changé oui
je ne peuvent y échapper non premier
pétard premier pétard n'ya pas longtemps
mais j'adore ça
et
voilà le nasa mal dans le film
téchiné vous amène
donc
et ma retraite chez vous attention on ne
bougera
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là c'est bien tous les cas il ya un truc
je vais bien répéter c'est qu'un léger
par un logiciel saas et bien déjà plongé
de recommencer parce que souvent pour
commencer alors là il ya quelques
questions dont j'ai les réponses vous
n'avez pas intérêt à me raconter des
conneries
par exemple premier baiser
l'âge est le nom du garçon oui 13 ans
oui c'est bien elle est pas menteuse
la première fois que vous avez fait
l'amour vous aviez quel âge et lui quel
âge 16 ans et lui 34 bravo le juge quel
âge aviez quand je vois des questions
non mais vous êtes allés avec votre
maman chez le gynécologue pour qu'il
vous donne la pilule
quel âge vous aviez quel âge vous aviez
même avec la première fois d'amour très
organisé une suite logique
attention j'ai toutes les réponses la
première fois à troyes
à 4 non plus l'un à 5 non plus non mais
attendez des gens qui font ça c'est pas
parce que vous êtes m à droite et il
somme sur roues arrière via connais les
chiffres impairs sait jamais première
fois avec une fille ça dépend quoi donc
rien on va vous avez fait l'amour avec
une fille jamais encore déplacement à
découvrir ça je suis pas je oui pourquoi
pas salir je deviens une expérience avec
une fille vos commandes du rallye
premier chagrin d'amour
j'ai pas vraiment eu de chagrin d'amour
non non vous êtes un sancerre mais c'est
vite au nombre à bord non première cuite
géraldine à la première dont je me
souvienne vraiment c'est le soir du bac
j'avais 17 ans ouais pourquoi parce que
vous l'aviez raté où l'avez vu je
l'avais raté j'étais la seule
ouais je comprends premier pétard 19 ans
j'étais passé car on est très tardif
jack sur le genre et mais entre-temps
dernières volontés si vous deviez mourir
là maintenant tout de suite c'est pas et
vous votre dernière volonté je deviens
mourir lannoy ça serai je veux pas je
veux pas
interview comme c'est la première fois
qu'on se voit première fois on ne bouge
pas pendant le single en bouche main
pendant les
bien premier souvenir estelle souvenirs
ses frais bo7 je sais pas la première
fois que j'arrive à paris première baffe
sur les fesses dans le dernier film j'ai
pas dix ans à l'âge de 10 ans je me
rappelle ces deux ans vous aviez fait
quoi vous souvenez j'avais failli faire
un incendie les gens attention alors
attention pour les questions suivantes
j'ai des réponses et pas intérêt à me
raconter des conneries premier baiser
quel âge d'abord sur la bouche et
qu'elle a rachetée par sa très bien avec
qui le prénom
il s'appelle ludovic nom cyrill ah oui
exact
je sais
oui c'est comme ça chose première fois
l'amour 16 ans et demi oui très bien et
le mec avec l âge ah ils étaient plus
vieux que moi il y avait 24
oui j'ai jabra wave 24 ans et c'était
dans une voiture la marque de la voiture
s'il vous plaît ce que vous écoutiez
mozart
non la maladie la première fois avec une
fille
j'avais 17 ans et demi première fois à
troyes je me rappelle putelat jeu mais
c'était après 17 ans j'avais déjà vers
18 ans et était bien coincé quand même
la première doit débloquer quand même
été timide et je t'aime première fois
beaucoup d'arrêts 18 19 ans là aussi
j'ai la réponse attention première
saudeau c'est bravo connais tout un
hier première saudeau et fellation en
même temps j'ai la réponse aussi ils
étaient deux dans projet x déjà bien des
femmes sur canal
le monsieur martin
ici on littéraire
par amour tu serais prêt prête à quoi
cette ambassade
tu vois enfin la question costume de
cour est-ce que par amour ou seriez
prête à embrasser cent fois les
chaussettes sales de votre fiancée faire
l'interview première fois vous êtes
prêts on ne bouge pas pendant avec une
gamme
ouais
qu'est ce que c'est que ça j'ai oublié
qu'il avait bougé enfin qu'il fallait je
sais pas je sais plus il n'a fait que
bouger je regardais les autres soeurs
qu'est ce qu'il a fait il a bougé ou pas
qu'est ce que tu en penses
comme dit l'interview voilà comme d'une
interview alors premier souvenir comment
mes parents ma mère m'a enfermé dans un
placard elle m'a oublié viennent mais
elle ne s'en souvient pas première prise
juste avant j'imagine des gens comme une
autre
l'âge de trois ans 6,35 terrible avant
j'avais tiré l'alarmé il y avait une
arme à la maison ça c est l art du
chauffeur de votre alarme du chauffeur
devant père j'ai pris un petit 6 35
chargé et je suis arrivé il y avait des
invités et j'ai fait aux les mains et
tout le monde a levé les mains
première aventure avec un garçon sage je
vous dis aventure aventure touche pipi
quoi il n'y a pas eu il ya eu une
période où j'étais tout le temps de
mettre tout nu avec des petits garçons
je sais pas si vous avez fait ça enfin
voulait bien sûr mais moi aussi j'ai
fait ça et là et donc vers un métier
terrain et c'était bah oui c'était ce
qui m'étonne c'est que ça se passait
très très rapidement grèce est 13
c'est très fatigant quoi premier baiser
on va en provence
j'étais un peu petit et gtc est monté
sur un tronc d'arbre
mais ça avait pris des heures avec des
précisions pour moi c'est la glace et ça
fait très vieux après pour ça recommence
isr surtout les jeunes je serai vieux je
moyens ça va beaucoup plus vite
première expérience sexuelle en
l'attention j'ai aussi la réponse je
vois tout à fait où c'était avec qui 16
ans ouais c'est ça chez un copain
pendant l'été mais jean-marc oui elle
s'appelait comment véronique bravo
[Applaudissements]
c'est là qu'il a ressorti son 6,35 qui
était chargé la première par tous
c'est parce que c'est bon j'ai jamais eu
ça mais bon alors une partie carrée ah
oui bon petit gars de 18 ans 19 ans et
vous me direz vous avez des partis car
est aussi oui je gêne pas pour courir
contre maubeuge et les parties car elle
vaut de quoi aider coup ils sont chassés
quand même d'accord très bon disque ça
va la forme vous fait vous êtes en forme
physiquement musicalement ça se passe
bien ouais c'est mon vieil panne -
étudier
[Musique]
la gauche pendant les gardes
premier souvenir je devais avoir un an
et demi ou deux ans et mon papa
m'emmenait dans un espèce de casting je
crois et je vais être sur scène et
bouger avec la chanson où la chanteuse
elle est amoureuse
non nous la menteuse elle est amoureuse
pas mal et je me sentais très mal et je
me suis mise à pleurer et
mon père m'a pris dans ses bras et on
m'a posé sur une table où il y avait
plein de chaussures et le mec qui
faisait le casting nous a demandé d'en
choisir une
et mon père a pris juste celle que je
voulais pas j'espérais vraiment qu'il
n'avait pas prendre saluant les vannes
d'un truc énorme mathieu c'est terrible
et pour en parler pendant des heures
c'est vraiment ça fait qu'il a marqué
tous là un beau fusil de casting très
jeunes enfants sur les musiques de
dorothée en plus la bête voilà ça donne
ça traumatisme terrible premier choc
le père noël n'existe pas à ça c'était
terrible j'ai pleuré ça m'a traumatisée
que l'âge 15 16 ans six en six ans un
premier péché l'envi de luxure peut-être
à 4 ans avec mathieu la coach
4 4 en quatre premières balles alors
celle dont je me souvienne mais c'était
sans doute pas la première je vais avoir
8 ans et et je courais pour pas que ma
maman me foute une baffe et helm a loupé
elle m'a tapé dans le ventre et ça m'a
fait très mal
yala père de l'enfant premier coup de
foudre faso mais tu m'as temps après
premier baiser sur la bouche dans une
fête en belgique jerry 12 ans avec la
langue alors en fait ça ces bases et
bizarrement voulait la vraie histoire
parce qu'il ya une série sans la langue
est en fait j'ai traversé la rue il y en
avait un autre qui était julien et oui
ça a été avec la langue d'accord le même
jour sur la vigne avec l'habitat leur
accorder toute première fois 14 ans avec
alex à bordeaux rejoint wayne ces jeunes
non ça c'est tout est de la faute de
mathieu sans doute lui lancé un appel
pour alex n'ont sans doute pas jacques
et mathieu en fait quel droit de revenir
quoi maintenant mais c'est l'espèce si
ça se trouve
inconsciemment je ne sais que chercher
l'image de mathieu que je ne retrouverai
jamais et c'est vrai que je le revois
pour quelle première fois à troyes
j'aimerais ballan trop de problèmes à 2
pourra être à 3 pour l'instant première
fois quatre soit à peine que je vous
demande non premier chagrin d'amour
vrai chagrin d'amour c'était il ya pas
très longtemps il ya enfin ça a duré
trois ans en fait aussi longtemps que
l'histoire et c'était avec mon petit ami
américain s'est vu comment michael
faisait quoi actares première tentative
de suicide
mathieu 15 en personne pourquoi je sais
plus dernière chose que vous feriez si
vous deviez mourir là maintenant tout de
suite
overdose de drogues dures
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
tu as touché si vous ne bougez et on
rallume zabou on va faire une interview
première fois en à gauche pendant l'été
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi je peux pas rivaliser vous vous êtes
comme des statues j'arrive pas assez dur
avant avant qui le dit il faut avoir
chopé une position qui est confortable
c'est comme ça sans me battre ici face à
ces radios sans exposition zabou premier
mensonge et je m'en souviens pas j'ai la
mémoire première fois où vous avez fait
pleurer votre mère à jeu une fois elle
était venue me coucher et puis je
voulais pas qu'elle s'en aille
je ne voulais pas qu'elle parte je
voulais qu'elle chante encore une
chanson est encore une chanson est
encore une chanson je m'étais pendu
littéralement à son cou accrochée et je
lui avais fait mal au cou et il avait pu
aurait alors là ça a été pour première
première belle robe première belle robe
alors pour moi mais bon pour moi petite
fille ça a été la panoplie d'isabelle en
l'as rome de mama pleinement en même
temps premiers flirts ckoi flirt la
roulage de pelle pelotage de leader tout
ceci se mélangent pas
avec avec la langue
mais mon premier flirt alors si vous
dites que c'est ça je l'épousé c'est lui
oui entre temps vous êtes un peu entre
temps ces kits été perdu de vue
oui ça nous a perdu une dizaine d'années
et puis on s'est retrouvés c'est beau du
vrai c'est très beau premier chagrin
d'amour
oui je me souviens je devais partir en
vacances avec lui il m'a dit
oh non en même temps il me dire au nom
du parti en vacances juste et au
téléphone je sais comment mais pourquoi
ai je dit mais la question qu'il faut
absolument pas posée je fais mieux que
tu m'aimes plus et m'a dit non m'a fait
ben non j'ai été abominable première
fois première fois c'était un peu comme
savez quand vous j'avais tellement les
chocottes que j'étais un peu comme quand
vous avalez un médicament périmé vite
vous buvez un grand verre d'eau ben
c'est bien expliqué
c'était pas comme des poèmes que
j'écrivais à 13 ans à bridas corp après
mêlée première fois c'était une première
expérience homosexuelle
demain demain dakar première fois à 3
après demain donc je vous demande pas un
4 en trois jours
[Rires]
sage quand même hein je sais pas si
c'est de la sagem première cuite d'avoir
15 ans j'avais bu un grand verre ne sais
pas quoi tous genres pastis ou un truc
comme ça ou deux il est malade comme un
chien et je me souviens qu'ils avaient
comme musique de fond
sister jane de comment ça s'appelait de
deux de taï phong quittait le groupe
oasis jane et moi je
add comme un chien était épouvantable
premier pétard à la campagne un truc
avait poussé dans le jardin d'un mec je
trouvais que c'était mauvais comme vous
et ils étaient tous très bizarre après
et moi je me suis dit il faut que ce
soit comme eux donc ils jouaient tous de
la batterie je ne suis pas pourquoi il
n'y avait pas de battre mais je vais
tout s'il était trop chaud place il
jouait de la batterie et je me suis dit
faut sûrement jouer de la batterie pour
comprendre pour les acides dans une
semaine comme et valium ah non je n'ai
pas pris lexomil oui j'en ai pris des
fois ça m'est arrivé une ou deux fois un
quart de ce petit truc qui est pas très
bon justement pour la mémoire s'est
prestement beaux jours qui prennent ça
comme ça on dirait que ça va me calmer
alors c'est pas bon du tout du tout pour
la mémoire c'est vraiment moche non pour
faire vraiment tout doucement
zabou premier film comme réalisatrice
là je m'en souviens oui c'est quoi se
souvenir des belles choses
vous aimez les belles choses avec
isabelle carré
et bien la campagne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
premier souvenir
renée saunier je pense que ça serait
vraiment ma première scène en fait tout
simplement parce que ça a été beaucoup
de stress pour moi et je m'en rappelle
encore donc c'est vraiment le souvenir
qui me revient là réfléchissons premier
objet fétiche
ben en fait c'est un grigri que j'ai
toujours et que j'ai trouvé il ya à peu
près trois ans avec l'homme avec qui je
suis aujourd'hui on la trouvait au bord
de la route et on a senti vu ce que
c'était ce que c'était une matière un
petit peu c'est quoi c'est quoi un petit
peu comme la sorcellerie
je pense que c'est ce que j'ai peur que
ça marche plus après matière voyez comme
les dents des trucs comme ça mais
d'animal c'est pas un truc d'êtres
humains qu'on a trouvé et c'est une
matière vivante en fait qu'on a trait au
bord de la route et c'était pas ça du
tout c'est pour ça que l'on ramassé 1 je
tiens à préciser ces patients latex non
non non je dirai pas ce que c'est parce
que je suis très superstitieuse mais
voilà c'est ça c'est un grigri en fait
que je mets dans une petite boîte donc
sceptique comme ça et là non par contre
je perds tout donc tous mes trucs porte
bonheur tous mérité que j'élève sûr mais
je me mets en relation avec et voilà
premier péché franchement je suis
tellement de sage moi j'aime pas
l'alcool on va dire ces cigarettes tout
simplement quand j'avais 14 ans puisque
le reste tout ce qui est c'est que je
veux dire c'est pas dépêcher pour moi ah
on aime quelqu'un qu'on est bien avec
lui c'est pas un péché non je ne
parlerai pas de ça tout seul ça a pêché
non conflit on va circulant chez gt gt
rekom olivier chez les curés donc pour
nous tous tes péchés n'est-ce pas tout
ce qui apporte du bonheur est pêché
voilà c'est ce candidat
dépêchez vous j'ai cambrioler une maison
quand j'avais 8 ans
première belle robe première belle robe
vraiment la première très très belle
c'était dans le métier quand j'ai fait
une cérémonie
c'était une remise de prix en fait
c'était comme les nrj music awards mais
une autre chaîne
donc vous savez pas quoi mais j'avais
vraiment une voiture le nom des autres
chaînes
je préfère pas quand même à bord il faut
dire que le show business maintenant les
discussions des chaînes concurrentes
chichi ça j'ai trouvé dire tous courir
ça ici m6 se voir le premier baiser
premier baiser j'avais 12 ans et je peux
dire son nom c'était yoann et ça s'est
très bien passé enfin j'étais vraiment
intimidé je me rappelle que quand on a
commencé à s'embrasser en était debout
et à la fin j'ai ouvert les yeux et
j'étais en fait à six ans les marges
escaliers parce qu'on était à l'arrêt
bus et donc je sais pas comment je me
suis retrouvé à six comme ça mais il a
dû se passer un tourbillon et qui m'a
fait tomber quoi c'est assez
impressionnant avec la langouste en
allemand avec la voyante là je sais pas
sans la langue n'était pas la langue on
ne met pas la langue premier flirt
poussé premier faire pousser je devais
avoir dix sept ans et c'était en fait
dans une ruelle juste en face de chez
moi donc je me rappelle que je devais
rentrer et ma mère était au balcon et
elle disait je l'entendais dire à mon
père mais qu'est ce qu'elle fait est
dors et déjà être là et du coup moi ça
m'a excité forcément de savoir mes
parents me chercher et on s'est mis dans
que contre la rue fin contre le mur et
là c'est vrai que ça a été la première
fois que c'était un peu plus poussées
mais justement on n'est pas passé à
l'acte c'est pas la première fois alors
très poussées mais pas plus première
fois avec un garçon 18 ans donc c'est
qu'un an après la première fois poussé
et
c'est toujours le même ah ouais ils sont
fidèles tout ceci c'est incroyable les
premières fois avec une fille
jamais un bon j'ai que 21 ans le
meilleur reste à venir je plaisante
combien tu as à 3 et jeunes et n'ont
plus jamais oser beaucoup de choses à
découvrir
jean faure vous raconter ma vie et fait
des découvertes
premier chagrin d'amour
j'en ai pas mal être il a commencé vers
mes 13 ans après que j'ai eu mon premier
garçon première tentative de suicide
jamais c'est pas très grave alors
recherche en allemand je m'en remets
toujours premiers valium témesta lexomil
jamais pas de drogue jamais quand même
pas de juin rien
la drogue douce on va dire oui
j'oubliais première infidélité
oui c'est vrai qu'avant ben justement
c'était à mes 17 ans il m'est arrivé
carrément de sortir avec 3 mais quand
même lourd mais j'ai senti que ça tirait
trop satana ils ne savaient pas
heureusement donc ça va gérer ça le
week-end
attention
le mois
pour nous
l'année comme s'il a parfois quand on se
voit on va faire une telle une première
fois dans la boucherie
[Applaudissements]
votre premier souvenir j'étais tout tout
tout tout bébé et les gens croient pas
quand je raconte ça mais j'étais bébé
parce que je pouvais pas marcher ni
avancer et ma mère était au dessus de
moi quand j'étais allongée et elle est
partie je sais pas chercher une couche
chercher un truc et j'ai eu un énorme
sentiment d'abandon de voir partir ma
maman elle pas pouvoir la suivre
je me souviens subventions ouais bah
voilà non mais c'est vrai je suis la
personne la croix là dessus
les deux puis vous raccrocher aux makes
à cause de ça voilà exactement 36
connaît votre premier choc si ici j'ai
failli me faire renverser par une
voiture
quand j'étais petit dans un camping
votre première baffe à je me souviens
que c'est la première et la seule c'est
mon père qui
ma chercher une bonne partie de la
soirée je devais avoir 12 13 ans n'ont
encore en camping on fait beaucoup de
campings et c'est très bien et j'étais
dans une soirée j'ai jamais quitté le
camping mais lui l'a fait tous les bars
du coin il est super peur et rentra il
m'a donné une baffe et je me suis fait
pipi dessus et à manger ou pas j'adore
c'est trop sexuel ça je te fais pipi
dessus
j'avais 12 ans a même 12 ans m'en fous
première idole
la première idole michel bouquet c'est
fou ça ouais j'ai toujours adoré michel
bouquet et vous adorez toujours way
toujours michel google rigueur à cette
heure là michel bouquet bolt revient
petit à petit ami mon premier petit ami
quoi pas sérieux ou sérieux un premier
petit thème les îles première série
passionnel je veux dire les doigts
palais doit d'abord les doigts c'est un
moyen sûr et dégueulasse et un ami en
fille et non pas si pressée non non je
suis resté un an avec lui
j'ai du mal à marcher à pied et voilà ça
a été un montagne c'est celui qui vous a
fait votre premier baiser sur la bouche
non alors premier baiser sur la bouche
oui baiser sur la bouche étaient encore
en camping c'est un cap d'agde likouala
premier baiser alors donc j'étais un
hollandais dont je me souvenais encore
laurent galles le cas des bulgares alors
essais voilà je me souviens qu'il était
vachement plus grand que moi et que les
points pour l'embrasser quoi il y avait
la langue ou pas il y avait la langue
tout de suite alors vous dès la première
fois ouais ouais j'ai super peur la
première fois avec un chien sueur ça je
viens par les envois ça va pas du tout
ah bon non non non non puisque c'est un
labrador je suis assez fier été très
très beau c'est d'un temple a ajouté m
votre mécha leur l'amour mon premier
chagrin d'amour géré mis du temps à m'en
remettre
labrador est parti c'est bien qu'ils
savaient pas écrire
ouais j'aime
ouais c'était un peu douloureux je suis
parti vivre à l'étranger pour essayer
vous êtes exilé ou à londres pendant
qu'en même temps on a foi neuf mois
tentative de suicide
ah non non quand même pas non plus
c'était pas c'est la séparation venait
de moi donc tu vas t'appeler n'ont pas
dit m lorsque j'ai avec moi mais les
gosses sérieusement c'est pourquoi vous
l'avez quittée je crois qu'on était
parti sur des mauvaises bases on était
super jeune quand on s'est rencontrés
quand on en reparle maintenant parce que
maintenant on est amis on rigole de
l'attitude qu'on avait un marcquois est
aujourd'hui et aujourd'hui vous êtes
combler tout va bien tu sais lequel elle
voit plus à voici
et
m
[Musique]
pour ce qu avait pas comment ce que
l'état on va faire une interview
première fois alors attention ça
commence simplement premier choc premier
choc
ah oui ça c'est quand comment papa était
parti de chez nous vous aviez 12 ans et
10 ans que vous apprenez que vos parents
avaient divorcé et ont divorcé au fait
parce que ma maman elle comptait la main
arrière quand elle a épousé mon père
elle était encore très jeune et puis ça
va pas vraiment si elle était amoureuse
ou palm époque elle est tombée enceinte
et puis c'était obligé qu'est-ce qu'elle
se marie et et quand j'avais 3 ans elle
a trouvé un autre en main sert à tomber
amoureuse il ya il ya soixante dentition
un truc que je pense à cette femme qui
qui d'un coup tombe sur un autre homme
qui lui convient mieux et c'est la vie
qui regarde je sais mais moi j'y arrive
de plus en plus se termine en divorce
c'est terrible c'est ça c'est terrible
parce que ça fait mal aux enfants le
scénario bien alors donc effectivement
commis le péché et chez qu'est ce que ça
fait chier à ses quelque chose de mal
qu'on a fait ou à la wii c'est quand
j'ai par là là c'est quand je suis parti
partie de la maison pendant trois jours
et ma mère savait pas où j'étais en fait
je suis parti avec les amis à moi on
était persuadé que c'était
un garçon et deux filles et on est parti
on savait même pas où dans une maison
faite le garçon il nous a dit j'ai les
clès et une maison à la campagne c'est
très sympa et tout et on atteint là on
est parti de la maison et à la fin on
s'est rendu compte qu'il n'avait pas de
créer en fait on est rentré dedans un
temps fort c'est assez contre l'al mais
c'est en république tchèque ce débat ici
[Musique]
premier coup de foudre j'ai eu 14 ans je
suis tombée amoureuse vraiment d'un
photographe non pas du tout attendre à
vous les filles sont toutes tombées en
photo moi n'ont jamais je pense que
non
pas parce que quelqu'un parte sécher
avec des photographes le soir la nuit
tombe très tôt aux seychelles non
samaras le pied tu n'es pas une fille
banale bien attention non là c'est ta
potala potage il va attention se
concentre avec un village et au but
ça faisait longtemps que les quinze
jours milla jovovich attend sûrement
attendre la place est très important on
se concentre irène premier baiser sur la
bouche sans la langue trop à ça je me
rappelle pas à 6 6 6 alors la première
fois quand même si non non non
oui c'était c'est un garçon que j'ai
confuse et gérant sort ensemble à
l'école et puis il arrive et me lance un
bisou sur la bouche et puis par tout de
suite c'est peu après je me suis rendu
compte que c'était lui c'était marrant
et avec la langue c'est vous en souvenez
je me souviens mais c'est qui j'avais 13
ans c'était à 59
il avait 15 15 alors et alors il
faudrait en fait beaucoup
moi je vous mets pas et quand j'ai
embrassé je trouvais pas ça ça me passe
tout et après je me suis brosser les
dents pendant cinq minutes
j'ai décidé de fumer au beaucoup plus
tard que voilà alors première fois il va
vous vous êtes retrouvé toute nue avec
un garçon un peu un peu bête comme ça un
peu bête comme ça oui je crois que
c'était en vacances avec avec mes
parents quand j'étais en espagne et il
savait rien moi j'ai rencontré ce garçon
était dans le même hôtel ne sait pas
comment faire
après oui à prendre le parti sur la
plage et puis on a assez un peu des
trucs mais ça n'a pas marché ça n'a pas
marché non la première fois que j'y ai
retrouvé nu avec un gars en avant que ça
t'a marqué
à eelv on arrive aux choses sérieuses
double tapotage première fois pour de
vrai avec un garçon vraiment c'était
juste 16 ans c'est une saison et c'est
avec 7,7 cette personne que j'aimais
c'était le premier coup de foudre et on
a attendu longtemps mais mes finances de
la santé deux ans oui mais ça s'est bien
passé
oui très bien bien alors première fois à
trois premiers x 3 bat on met pas trois
sets c'était et away j'ai eu
j'ai eu 17 ans ça s'est bien passé oui
très bien
première fois avec un animateur télé
jamais même en co animateur
[Musique]
alors maintenant johnny comme c'est la
première fois que je te reçois je vais
te faire une interview première fois
[Musique]
alors jailli ton premier non tout le
monde croit que c'est se met en fête
c'est clair comme julien c'est le nom de
ta mère parce que ton père était assez
volage il a attend mois chez claude
moine
non les stagiaires qui vont sillonner
ton père était quelqu'un d'assez bas
tellement fait pour la pas tellement
fait pour la pour la vie de famille et
quelques jours après la naissance il a
vendu les meubles il affronte du même
l'année y est
dix jours après la naissance il rendit
vite un et six mois plus tard il a
quitté le domicile conjugal et donc ta
mère s'est retrouvé comme ça toute seule
et elle a retrouvé un an après elle a
obligé à l'épouser mais ton vrai nom ton
vrai premier non c'est clair mais ce
domaine c'est huguette clair jusqu'au
mariage avec au mariage de ma mère
c'était clair qui était mannequin chez
fat
oui une très jolie femme qui vit
toujours et qui vit toujours méfiant
comme je crois que les fans bien réussi
quand même quoi qu'on en dise c'est vrai
que c'est un peu un voyou mais bon être
la maman de johnny doit elle doit être
fier je veux donner du tracas un oui
mais bon c'est faire bien du souci alors
ce père léon se mettent donc johnny vous
le reverrez vingt ans plus tard vous
vous avez 21 ans fait le service
militaire en allemagne
et un jour il ya un mec qui vous dit il
fallait à l'entrée de la caserne
on vous y allez c'est un ordre vous y
allez et à ce moment là vous voyez un
type qui se jettent sur vous en disant
johnny johnny monfils est en vous
mettant un ours en peluche dans les bras
et c'était votre père et quelques années
plus tard vous apprendrez qu'en fait
c'était un coup qu'il avait monté avec
les paparazzi oui mais enfin bon ça
s'est passé
ouais je préfère pas trop parler de ça
vous l'avez vachement et d après quand
même votre père non oui enfin j'ai fait
ce que j'ai pu mais c'était pas toujours
facile parce que j'avais pris un
appartement et puis je reçois des coups
de téléphone dans la nuit comme quoi il
avait mis le feu à l'appartement ils
examinent non
excuse moi mais c'est vrai nom gpj j'ai
essayé beaucoup de choses depuis un
moment donné j'ai un message pour dire
que tu me pique mes veines éclatant mais
non c'est vrai qu'en voulu acheter des
costumes cerrutti d'aller les revendre
quand quand vous lui louer un
appartement il mettait le feu
effectivement donc c'était assez assez
désespérant finalement le procès comme
il était alors au bout d'un moment j'ai
baissé les bras mais j'ai fait ça il a
dit qu'il voulait avoir
reggiani vous à vous a parlé d'une fois
qu'un jour je te rencontrer djallit qui
me dit tu sais je sais que tu as eu une
mauvaise impression de temps permet moi
j'allais prendre des cours tous les tous
les week-ends à bruxelles chez lui
c'était un professeur d'art dramatique
extraordinaire ben ouais et puis un jour
vous allez l'enterrement de ce père un
petit peu inconnu d'une certaine façon
enchère bic en belgique j'ai presque ému
et ce qui m'a attristé ce qui va avoir
d'abord étonné mais en laissant tous
attristés c'est que j'étais tout seul il
y avait personne
ouais c'est bien la première fois que tu
étais tout seul intrus mais ce n'était
pas gay dans cette histoire c'est un
petit peu déboussolé un d'une certaine
façon cette envie que vous avez eue
après de créer une famille et pas y
arriver c'est peut-être dû à ça
finalement sans faire de la psychanalyse
à deux balles
c'est peut-être ça l'histoire non il
faut d'abord avant de créer une famille
il faut tomber sur la bonne personne
n'était jamais tombé sur la bonne
personne et cette fois-ci bon cette fois
ci je crois que suis bien entendu
ouais ça a l'air attendu sur une fois
avec son numéro 1 qui je suis très
heureux et belle était temps parce que
alors vous avez été élevé par votre
tante hélène marais votre première scène
c'est à 4 ans vous en souvenez de ça en
47 à londres non non dans une pièce ce
qui s'appelle caligula de camus fait le
rôle d'un petit nain petit ne veulent
pas du tout premier souvenir me
souvenais c'est à londres
ben quoi c'est le doigt dans un rail
d'escalators
première guitare quel âge vers avoir 12
ans ouais vous étiez à rome avec vos
cousins des stars elie et vous avez à ce
moment-là rencontré un guitariste de
flamenco
il choisit une tournée théâtrale époque
là où il y avait comme ça des tas de
numéro 2 de music hall 1 il y avait des
gitans et avait des acrobates bon et il
y avait dans la troupe des gitans il y
avait un guitariste flamenco qui m'a
appris à jouer un peu du temps
la jota la rivale plein de choses et ça
m'a vraiment plu et ensuite on m'a
acheté une guitare donc avec des cordes
à caen se cacher car milan le retour au
flamenco bientôt bientôt premier rôle au
cinéma 1954 en semaine et diabolique
vous aviez une petite annonce dans
france soir et comme il n'est pas de blé
à la maison votre temps de vous avez
emmené là bas j'avais passé un casting
et prix web dans l'état dans la classe
d'enfants mais j'étais la figuration ce
n'est pas un robin j'avais deux phrases
à dire qui a été coupée donc ça ne veut
pas très bon on vous voit dans le film
vous laver les dents vous savez ça oui
je suis au premier cachet de johnny
hallyday en 1955 à un oeuvre premier
cachet c'est un coca cola vous aviez
chanter davy crockett sur celle ci
souvient de cette chanson de hockey
david avait craqué n'a jamais chanté en
duo avec johnny j'ai fait mon premier
duo avec
c'était en 2003 mais vous êtes montés
très très tôt sur les planches à
repasser ce qu'on sait ce qu'on découvre
mais c'est normal parce que j'ai été
élevé par une par une famille d'artistes
voyager beaucoup qui faisait beaucoup
music hall beaucoup de cabaret donc je
voyais pas très honnêtement je ne me
voyais pas comptable plus tard je me
voyais plutôt artistes mais ça ne va pas
me perturber sa d'être sur scène
aussitôt non non c'est comme jeu comme
j'en ai fait mon métier c'est plutôt une
chance pringy j'ai eu le temps
d'apprendre avant d'être connu
maintenant ce que je m'attends à ce que
ce que je reproche un petit peu c'est
qu'on lance d'aider des gens on essaie
de leur apprendre à danser à chanter en
quatre mois on les lance comme des stars
ils n'ont pas le temps ils n'ont pas ils
n'ont pas et ils n'ont ils n'ont pas eu
là comment dire la formation la
formation
merci merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
jeanine de strasbourg pour pour pour
aller sur une scène d'être lancée comme
star il faut apprendre son métier avant
et on en laisse pas le temps d'apprendre
alors effectivement quand on les voit
sur scène la première fois les gens
peuvent être peut-être déçu ce n'est pas
que le fait d'une zone de chantier qui
est important c'est le fait de savoir
aller et sortir d'une scène et savoir
bouger sur une selle en fait un forain
quoi je suis un oui en quelque sorte oui
c'est pas péjoratif
non non pas du tout j'adore les formats
info alors première bagarre c'était avec
la bande de la trinité non j'imagine et
avait dutronc il y avait longue crise il
y avait dit michel thiry vous preniez
des dérouillées par les mecs de la bande
du sacré coeur où la bande de la
bastille ouais ils étaient plus nombreux
qu'aux métiers combien vaut alors ils
étaient une vingtaine un essai deux sens
c'était plié votre première petite amie
vous en souvenez ma première petite
taille moyenne elle vous regarde
elle est la première petite amie c'est
claude pécha bravo rentrant puisqu'à
l'époque vous n'aviez pas encore de
voiture alors votre première idole c'est
brassens c'est fait vous auriez voulu
avoir brassens avec les grosses vestes
en velours il est qui est rassurant
c'est rassurant pas de brel aussi c'est
une de vos premières idoles et et vous
dit s'il avait fait du rock qui nous
aurait tous enterrés
c'est vrai parce que il chante avec sa
poésie les il l'interpréter sur scène
avec l'énergie et le désespoir d'un
rockeur je ne connais pas d'autres
chanteurs que brel 1 qui transpirait
autant et qui vomissait avant de rentrer
sur celles à long mais tous les records
le bovespa avant qu'ils tracent plus
ricky zone et qui seront faire autant
qu'un kkk
vous trouvez ça bien là qu'on aurait dit
des choses qui voulaient pas voir éditer
écoutez tout le monde évidemment curieux
long terme ça mais par rapport à sa
mémoire se trouve ça très bien alors dit
moi il ya des trucs à toi comme ça qui
ont été faits que personne n'a entendu
hier dans quelques j'ai réalisé le feu
j'ai senti dans ta première qu'est ce tu
t'en souviens c'était une triumph
blanche un bravo une tr 3 18 ans dès
qu'il a eu la première boîte
août est sorti août est rentré déjà
ouais tu vois tu je suis sorti alors là
ça c'est pas j'en ai fait beaucoup
la première à l'époque la banque de la
trinité j'imagine ont à leur tour un peu
trop et c'est sa première boîte comme
propriétaire c'est celle qui ouvre sa et
2003 voilà 2003 il aura fallu attendre
2003 pour que johnny hallyday et sa
boîte à lui ouais mais ça une histoire
celle de boîtes que que j'ai monté là on
va en parler en rimes
[Musique]
valeria bruni tedeschi votre premier
péché oulala je vais je vais y arriver
pourquoi y en a tellement mais je me
suis toujours sentie coupable je sais
pas en fait de quoi
mais j'ai dû faire un péché dont je me
souviens pas c'était le péché originel
pourrait peut-être peut-être s'est
jamais remise du péché originel m vous
êtes tout le temps le sentiment d'être
dans le péché dj plus loin que je m'en
souvienne est là aussi
ouais vous dire mais je vous dis je
m'exile c'est pas bien c'est la vanité
je venais d'être chez moi en train de
préparer deux films suivants travailler
au lieu de baver la télévision qui peut
même quand c'est pas quand c'est pas
apprécié ces vaccins sentiment vague et
sauces comme ça depuis toujours ah oui
mais aussi à non c'est vrai j'ai une
espèce de culpabilité l'attend voilà
exactement ouais non mais c'est vraiment
et ça rend pas heureux non mais alors je
trouve ça et je sauve c'est papa y aller
vous êtes entrain de sympathiser ça se
passe bien je vois bien je la bloque
non c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
je fais un travail
pourquoi il devrait y passer bah si vous
il faut vraiment s'en tira grand grande
grande nécessité
c'est pas qu'on le fasse comme ça je
crois qu'on le fait que c'est bien de
faire quand qu'on peut pas faire
autrement
il paraît qu'après on s'accepte moi j'ai
pas tellement envie de m'accepter
non vous l'être contre vous ouais le
jour je n'accepterai j'aurais baissé les
bras non ah non je crois pas on commence
quand tous acceptés s'ils acceptent
grande
bah oui mais mais du coup il ya la place
pour pour regarder alors si on est tout
le temps en train de faire la guerre on
est occupé à faire la guerre je vous
pourriez beaucoup m'apporter valérien
votre première idole c'est qui peut-être
un décor dit annie cordy est la bonne
dynamique et c'est vrai des patrouilles
écoutes foot s'en souvenait de ça quand
même
ah ouais c'était qui se passe très bien
oleg menchikov il était quoi est il
était italo russe et je ne savais pas ce
qui se passait et je crois que je suis
tombée amoureuse mais je savais pas ce
que c'était
alors premier coup de foudre on a vu
c'était oleg menchikov si tu nous
regardes le legs première fois pour de
vrai vous en souvenez quand on regarde
son pendant vingt quoi devrais l'amour
pour de vrai qu assez triste
à sète et triste oui vous ne regardez
pas non c'est sérieux culpabiliser
encore sur la non mais c'est toujours
c'est toujours un peu triste un peu gay
en même temps quand on avance dans la
vie on laisse un truc derrière c'est
fini tu finis une chose qui est finie
c'est une vraie nostalgique non je suis
très s'agit quoi moi aussi ouais il ya
un sentiment terrible il s'appelle le
mariage aux effets d'échelle et je leur
en laisse ou là il ya un truc
laurent et l'omt a eu raison de tenir
derrière il ya un truc est en train de
se passer je crois qu'on est réellement
en train de sympathiser très fort toi tu
préférais la soeur battu voix
mme chan
[Applaudissements]
pour la première fois la première fois
qu'un garçon vous m'avez dit c'était
oleg menchikov la première fois avec une
fille valeria jamais la première fois à
3 à 4 mais je vais pas répondre des
choses comme ça c'est cgppa jamais on en
était la première fois 4 je sais pas moi
attendent et je suis moi j'ai un boulot
à faire à chaud je suis ma liste de
questions voilà je suis jeune et je vais
pas sauter non plus oui attendez
excusez-moi valeria notre ami et c'est
elie semoun et du buzz qui sont ensemble
comment ça va j'entendais fit rire
qu'est ce qui à l'homosexualité c'est
quelque chose qu'on a pas un droit de
vie je veux dire c'est des êtres humains
comme tout le monde on s'aime et puis
c'est tout oui ça va bien vous devez
arrête toi qui aime bien avoir des
scoops bah voilà on est ensemble
voilà nous vous regarde sur l'amour
verbalement et puis on aime ça et ta
femme elle le prend comme ans et lis et
j'entends mal
bien non ça se précise avec c'est vrai
alors on en est valeria première rupture
gg l'est j'ai pleuré m'a quitté ah ouais
c'est lui qui nous a quittés vous êtes
le rêve ça durait depuis quinze jours
première cuite
ah oui c'était quoi bein je m'en
souviens pas parce que je sais combien
fuite dans une épave première tentative
de suicide quoi un bon tir et johnny
quoi toi plus léger sursis venir ici
pour elle c'est une petite tentative de
suicide
on se concentre et si vous n'arrivez pas
à répondre aux questions séverine bohic
secrètement la première fois tout seul
jeu favori en tout cas version 6 mois à
6 mois déjà
habillement non mais voilà une bonne
réponse britz julian fantino un peu tard
c'est moi c'est ce que je me suis dit
vous n'aurez pas que des joker la
première fois avec une fille
hier soir dans mes rêves le premier
bisou le premier bisou à un garçon un
petit bijou dos c'est moi je sais pas 8
en 8 ans oui récréation puis 57 quand
même faire un choix
le premier baiser là pour le coup le
premier vrai baiser avec un garçon et la
hongrie a deux garçons et la l'envers on
a 12 ans
le premier flirt poussé poussé jusqu où
leur poussée ça veut dire un truc
laurent laurent tapotage la première
fois l'amour pour de vrai c'est à dire
quinze mois j'ai moi même une fille de
15 ans est-ce que je peux poser une
question non c'est pas un peu tôt 15 ans
j'ai une fille de 14 ans - oui mais qui
en fait son métier non non
aller dans une école
c'est un saint pé de [ __ ] c'est
certes ils n'ont simplement est-ce que
c'est pas un peu ton c'est non c'est pas
je mangeais très heureuse et gt gt prat
et j'avais le tapage voilà quoi bien
passé non tu penses à ta ma fille vient
j'aimerais qu'on attende 20-25 qu'elle
tombe bien sûr les luçonnais des
abeilles avant de parler du pollen il ya
plein de choses on n'a jamais parlé bien
oui alors le premier grand amour tu sais
premier chagrin d'amour
dix sept à huit jours qu'est ce qui
s'est passé ça allait pas qu ils vous
avaient argué non c'est on s'est quittés
enseignants semblent cqt enseignants ça
s'en va et ça revient
elle est parti de lui partout
ça va ça prouve qu'on verra jamais je
crois que la conduite de l'entrée s'est
arrêté sur mehdi way à cet instant très
précis qui veulent perpétuer par type et
je suis parti c'est vraiment le muppets
avec son embout
la première fois vous avez fait l'amour
à trois têtes une via la ville oui c'est
ça
jamais non c'est un joker vous vous
dites jamais que si c'est un joker c'est
bine pire est lamentable
à faire l'interview première fois alors
votre premier souvenir
ma grand mère qui m'apporte un verre de
lait avec des deux gâteaux les deux
gueules soir votre premier choc choc à
quoi une voiture m'a renversé
vous aviez quel âge en votre premier
mensonge si je mens tout le temps oui le
premier péché par faire l'amour qu'elle
est mignonne qu'en tennis a dit non le
premier coup de foudre
jamais jamais jusqu'à maintenant c'est
vrai jusqu'à maintenant
comment il faisait cette émission avec
moi et heureusement que tu n'es plus là
tu me casses tous les coups il est
jaloux peuvent que j'ai embrassé sur la
bouche et maintenant je m'intéresse à
quelqu'un ne casse pas tous les coups la
première jeune fille qui tressent des
roses c'est bon le premier sur la bouche
sans la langue
c'était au vous savez les corses
appellent les compagnies comme avant ça
existait mais j'étais dans un lieu jeudi
à mardi jusqu'au 10/10 on en était là
bas et le premier baiser avec la langue
c'est avec ce garçon de l'allemand cours
de danse le premier flirt poussé avec un
garçon un flirt poussé enfin vous
appreniez les termes le flirt poussé
alors que ce qui s'est fait repousser ce
type il aurait quand même car si lui
montrer où c'est ça à fleurs poussent et
on fait tout sauf tous voila a toujours
le même votre première expérience
homosexuelle
ça y est je savais dans les eaux merde
c'est un secret je n'ai pas bu première
fois à troyes pour faire 3 a frappé par
mois à peu près vingt dix chez vous
première fois à 4 ha
j'ai regardé comme il faut bien d'amour
ouais peut-être j'avais 15 ans et un
garçon qui était un grand succès le
danseur c'est vrai mais j'étais triste
mais bon c'est pas un chagrin parce que
comme n'y a jamais eu des bus était pas
vous avez vous avez des races et avait
l'air un peu froide avec tout ça c'est
la perrière de vraiment vous passionner
ouais non bâti sentimentale que ça moi
comment pourtant vous êtes scorpionvous
n'en oui a très bien et les scorpions
seb le sexe quand même je vous trouve
trop énorme
non j'ai choisi champions il y en a qui
baissent très non mesdames elle vous
êtes sentimentale quand même sentimental
jeu le match benoît être si sentimentale
que salga finalement peut-être de temps
en temps des fois ça dépend vous n'êtes
pas amoureuse en ce moment un bon déjà
[Musique]